mario paul
sous un déluge de feu
mais marioupol n'est pas encore tombée
les russes et les séparatistes
contrôlent la quasi totalité de la ville
mais a à peine quelques centaines de
mètres au bout de cette rue les
ukrainiens résiste dans l' usine d'azov
ce talent elle est pilonnée sans relâche
des soldats séparatistes nous accompagne
pour eux la dernière bataille de
marioupol est lancé
on prépare l'assaut terrestre avant
d'envoyer au plus près nos groupes
d'assurances quote c'est d'abord
l'artillerie qui tirent
là bas lusine a été transformé en
forteresse par les ukrainiens elle est
difficile à prendre les bâtiments
s'étendent sur une immense superficie et
il y a des souterrains sur plusieurs
niveaux
mais partout tout autour
des blindés
les combattants ukrainiens sont
complètement encerclée
pour ce français qui a rejoint les
forces séparatistes pro-russes la
victoire est à portée de main peu
pathétique meubles deux carrés
d'immeubles et ensuite c'est déjà lusine
il ya un petit parc et luzi et limiers
la terrre du terrain les russes ont
lancé un ultimatum aux ukrainiens il
devait se rendre avant la mi journée
hors de question répond kiev marioupol
est devenu un symbole c'est la plus
grande ville du donbass qu'ils n'ont pas
complètement perdu j'ai un agent
l'élimination de nos militaires de nos
hommes des chenaux arbre un mario paul
on stoppe aux jeans mettra fin à toutes
négociations hier matin
dans cette usine d'azov talent il y à
des combattants ukrainien qui n'ont
presque rien à perdre ce sont les
combattants du bataillon azoff c'est
l'ennemi juré de la russie qui n'arrête
pas de le qualifier de bataillon nazis